[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
es gab ein Ort in eigentlich ganz
Deutschland wo Bandidos und Hells Angels
Tür an Tür lebten und es war ein
permanent im Brisanz bis dann irgendwann
die Bordellbetreiber auch gesagt haben
wir wollen die Rocker nicht mehr haben
die zerstören uns das ganze Geschäft ich
habe noch versucht zu helfen als der
Mann der in der Vulkanstraße auf dem
Boden lag ich wollte die Blutung
irgendwie stehen aber da war nicht zu
machen er blutete ganz doll überall lief
es heraus aus dem Kopf hinter dem linken
Ohr und aus der Nase man konnte einfach
nichts dagegen tun
zwei sehr eindringliche O-Töne zum
Anfang das waren Bildreporter Frank
Schneider und eine Augenzeuge in deren
Erinnerungen wir nachgesprochen haben
und wir stecken immer noch mittendrin im
Rockerkrieg von Nordrhein-Westfalen ich
bin Toni Hayer und ich bin Mirko Kasimir
hallo wir führen heute Geschehnisse
sofort die in den 2000er Jahren mit
einem Überfall im Rockermilieu ihren
anfangsnamen schön dass ihr auch im
zweiten Teil mit dabei seid
in Teil 1 haben wir mit Hilfe von Frank
Schneider ja erzählt wie Bandidos im
nordrhein-westfälischen Ibbenbüren einen
Hells Angels erschossen aus Rache für
einen brutalen Überfall mit
Baseballschlägern die beiden Mörder in
diesem Fall wurden 2008 in Münster zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt während des
Prozesses lieferten sich zum Teil
hunderte Rocker auf ihren Motorrädern
eine Art Schaulaufen in Münster keine
Seite wollte der anderen das Feld
überlassen aber nach dem Urteilsspruch
wollten die beiden Organisationen ihre
Ruhe haben denn bei Rockerbanden geht es
zwar viel um Coolness Männlichkeit und
Ehre aber am Ende doch hauptsächlich um
das Geschäft oder sagen wir es mal so um
lupenreines organisiertes Verbrechen um
Prostitution Drogenhandel
Schutzgelderpressung oder
Steuerhinterziehung
also trafen sich Hells Angels und
Bandidos im Winter nach dem Urteil zu
einem Friedensgipfel in einem Hotel in
Magdeburg am Ende verkündeten die Chefs
ihr gemeinsames Abkommen aber Spoiler
wenn es gehalten hätte dann würden wir
diesen zweiten Teil der Episode nicht
machen aber wie gesagt es kam halt eben
anders Mirko an vielen Stellen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen gibt es in der Zeit
nach dem Friedensschluss weitere
Reibereien besonders brisant ist die
Lage in der Duisburger Vulkanstraße wie
bildchef Reporter Frank Schneider
anfangs schon schilderte residieren
Hells Angels und Bandidos hier quasi Tür
an Tür
Hintergrund war das die Bandidos ihr
Clubheim direkt am Bordell hatten Teil
es Bordells aber wiederum von Hells
Angels kontrolliert und das heißt man
war dort ständig Konfrontation
ausgesetzt und dann gab es damals immer
die du Ashley eine Größe auch in der
Hooligans Szene das war immer schon bei
demandilos so dass sie im Bereich der
Hooligans auch sehr viele Mitglieder
rekrutiert haben er war bei Schalke 04
bei der gelsen Szene und eine galt als
eissporn als aggressiv und provozieren
und er hat dann vor dem Band auf der
Straße gestanden und dann fuhr damals
Timur a vorbei und der kam von Bordell
dann der Vulkanstraße also der saß im
Auto der Stand auf dem Gehweg und hat
man sich gegenseitig provoziert und dann
soll erschläge gesagt haben wir kommen
noch her und er hat eine Waffe gezogene
Timo und Ashley wichtig zurück und sagt
ja dann schieß doch und dann hat er
geschossen und hat ihn auch im Kopf
getroffen und er schläft war sofort tot
er hatte keine Chance der ist dann erst
noch abgehauen der timo hat sich dann
aber später gestellt und das war eine
Eskalationsstufe und hat die Polizei
wirklich Monate mehr oder weniger mit
einer Hundertschaft das ganze Gebiet
abgeriegelt bis dann irgendwann über der
Betreiber auch gesagt hat wir wollen die
Rocker nicht mehr haben die zerstören
uns das ganze Geschäft
also nochmal ganz in Ruhe wir schreiben
Donnerstag den 8 oktober 2009 für
Schlagzeilen sorgen eigentlich planbare
beschauliche Neuigkeiten die königlich
Schwedische Akademie der Wissenschaften
vergibt an diesem Tag den Nobelpreis für
Literatur an die deutsch-rumänische
Schriftstellerin Hartan Müller
weitere Meldungen in seiner Festrede zum
60-jährigen Bestehen der
Bundespressekonferenz fördert
Bundespräsident Horst Köhler die
politischen Journalisten zu mehr
Ernsthaftigkeit auf aber wegen der
Ereignisse in Duisburg macht jetzt der
Rockerkrieg wieder Schlagzeilen soeben
hat der Hells Angels Timo a den Bandido
Rudi heinzelten Spitzname Ashley auf
offener Straße niedergeschossen weitere
Schüsse verfehlten nur knapp zwei völlig
Unbeteiligte Frauen
anschließend flüchten der Täter Timor
und sein Bruder
Elton stirbt noch in der Notaufnahme der
Schütze stellt sich einen Tag später bei
der Polizei und damit ist der Frieden
dahin wieder gibt es spektakuläre Bilder
von rockaufmärchen am 16 oktober 2009
wird Ashley in Gelsenkirchen auf dem
Hauptfriedhof beerdigt für die
Trauerfeier Reisen aus ganz Europa
insgesamt 1.500 Bandidos an motorradlärm
lässt die umliegenden Wohngegenden
erzittern vielleicht fühlen sich die
Rocker durch diesen gigantischen
auftrittsstark vermutlich aber was fest
steht die Öffentlichkeit muss brechen
der Polizeieinsatz rund um die
Beisetzung verursacht Kosten von rund
600.000 Euro immerhin passiert an diesem
Tag nichts schlimmes mehr aber natürlich
muss sich der Rechtsstaat weiter mit
diesem Rockerkrieg herumschlagen
[Musik]
Programm 25 März 2010 und der großen
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen hat am
Donnerstag der Mordprozess gegen einen
31-jähriges Mitglied der rockerband der
Hells Angels am Landgericht Duisburg
begonnen im Streit um eine Frau soll
Timo
a132-jähriges Mitglied der Bandidos für
eine Rocker Kneipe in Duisburg
erschossen haben die Schüsse gab der
Täter am 8 oktober 2009 aus seinem Auto
heraus ab auch auf zwei Frauen soll er
gezählt haben die sich aber unverletzt
retten konnten
an dem Prozess kann sich auch
Bildreporter Frank Schneider gut
erinnern dabei ist rausgekommen dass
auch in dem Fall auch wiederum eine Frau
ging also auch Geschäftsinteressen aber
um eine Frau auch wiederum Ehre denn
eigentlich war das die Freundin von
Ashley die gleichzeitig aber sich
komischerweise mit dem Hells Angel im
Timo auch getroffen hat sie verdient er
behauptet sie hätte nicht als
Prostituierte gearbeitet es gab andere
Hinweise dass sie in Teilen doch
gearbeitet hat für wen der beiden auch
immer oder mal für den mal für den warum
diese Frau dieses Spiel gespielt hat und
dieses unglaubliche Risiko auch für sich
eingegangen ist weiß man nicht aber am
Ende ging es da auch um eine Frau und
Provokation und jeder betrachtete diese
Frau wohl als sein Eigentum so muss man
das leider sagen so sind die Rocker
unterwegs gewesen die Frauen die für Sie
gearbeitet haben das waren ihre Frauen
da hatte kein anderer was zu suchen und
das hat dann zu dieser Eskalation
geführt aber auch da wieder im Ende
geht's immer um Ehre und um Geld
Werbung heute stelle ich euch einen
neuen Roman vor Sekunden der Gnade von
Dennis
times Bestseller Autor nimmt uns mit ins
Boston der 70er Jahre es herrscht
aufgeheizte Stimmung die Stadt kocht
denn künftig sollen schwarze Kinder mit
Bussen in weiße Schulen gebracht werden
und umgekehrt Angst und Hass machen die
Runde eines Nachts kehrt Mary Pet
fennessee 17-jährige Tochter joules
nicht nach Hause zurück Mary Pets
beginnt Fragen zu stellen aber sie stößt
auf schweigen und Widersprüche bis sie
begreift man hat ihr das letzte genommen
was ihr in dieser Welt Halt gab außer
sich vor Schmerz macht sie sich auf um
Rache zu nehmen an den Verantwortlichen
und ihre eigene Schuld zu sühnen und das
um jeden Preis große Erzählkunst
messerscharfe Psychologie bewegendes
Drama und spannend wie ein Thriller
Sekunden der Gnade von Dennis lehan ist
jetzt erschien im Diogenes Verlag
Werbung Ende
das Urteil für den Todesschützen Timur A
11 Jahre Haft wegen Totschlags Mord
stand von Anfang an nicht zur Debatte
schließlich war die Tat ganz
offensichtlich nicht heimtückisch
geplant sondern aus einem Wort Gefecht
entstanden der Vorsitzende Bericht der
Joachim schwarz sagt zum Urteilsspruch
das war das individuelle Finale eines
Konfliktes zweier Motorradclubs Täter
und Opfer haben sich am Tatabend wie
schon oft zuvor feindselig gegenüber
gestanden wir sind davon überzeugt dass
keine Notwehrsituation vorgelegen hat
der Angeklagte hat mit dem festen Willen
gehandelt den anderen Rocker zu töten
Täter wie Opfer haben die Eskalation
förmlich hinaufbeschworen weil sie ihr
Gesicht nicht verlieren wollten sie der
Angeklagte haben zum Beispiel die
Gelegenheit verstreichen lassen einfach
loszufahren als die Ampel wieder auf
Grün stand
mit dem Urteil ist ein weiteres Kapitel
im Rockerkrieg beendet die Morde 2007
und 2009 über die wir jetzt berichtet
haben die geraten in Vergessenheit aber
das rocker-problem bleibt Frank
Schneider also diese rockerstrukturen
haben sich ganz eigenartig entwickelt
man muss sagen damals in die zu Zeiten
dieses Krieges wo die beiden
Tötungsdelikte auch passiert sind haben
beide Seiten wirklich wild angeworben
dann gab es auch teilweise so dass es ja
noch holländische Rocker dies Tattoo
Dara Rocker gehabt da gab es plötzlich
Gremium da tauchten ja ganz verschiedene
rockergruppierungen auf dann gab es noch
die Mongols das war eine ganz wilde Zeit
und irgendwann hat die Polizei halt
massiv dagegenhalten weil sie gemerkt
haben es geht so nicht weiter gerade
auch da wieder in Duisburg wo diese
hollandrocker eben unterwegs waren von
Tattoo Dara der flogen dann plötzlich
Handgranaten in ladenlokales wurde mit
Langwaffen Maschinenpistolen geschossen
und hat die Polizei anderer seit jetzt
reicht ist massiv dagegen vorgegangen
und hat ja dann auch das sogenannte
kundenverbot damals eingeführt und ich
bin ganz ehrlich ich habe da am Anfang
nicht dran geglaubt dass das jetzt viel
bringen soll aber es hat was gebracht in
der Öffentlichkeit hat nicht mehr so
funktioniert
man muss aber auch sagen am Ende waren
das auch keine rockerstruktur mehr dir
fuhren gar nicht keine Harley mehr
darüber mehr Motorradführerschein es
ging eigentlich nur noch um masse statt
Klasse sozusagen und man wollte
möglichst viel sein und am Ende muss man
sagen sind die Strukturen der
Kleinkriminalität von migrantischen
Strukturen sehr da reingewachsen dass
sie Hells Angels am Ende eigentlich fast
überhaupt gar keine deutschen Mitglieder
mehr hatten die Deutschen Mitglieder
auch an den Rand gedrängt wurden auch
selbst ein Hahne gut hatte kaum noch
Einfluss in der Szene so geraten zwar
vielleicht einzelne Figuren bei den
Rockern aus dem Blickwinkel aber das
Problem ist bis heute nicht gelöst das
zeigte z.B der Mord im Berliner Wettbüro
im Jahr 2014 das zeigen Fälle die bis
heute reichen und am Ende des Jahr noch
mal zu einem internen Mord aufgeführt
der jetzt aktuell vor Gericht verhandelt
wird und zwar der zerstückelte Rocker
aus dem Rhein km ein herzinsel der von
den eigenen neuen getötet wurde mit dem
Argument der seinen Spitzel gewesen das
war aber entweder nur ein bloßer
Verdacht oder sogar nur ein bloßer
Vorwand weil einzelne Rocker ihn nicht
mochten weil er hat einen Schlag bei
brauner war beliebt und das passte wohl
oft bei dem rockerpräsidenten nicht das
ist jeweils Teil der Anklage das ist
darum ging und er wollte ein besonders
Patch haben nämlich dieses filzy view
Patch nach dem Motto man hat einen
Verräter oder einen Gegner schwer
verletzt oder getötet und da schließt
sich auch sozusagen wieder der Kreis
denn bei dem Mord an Robert K 2007 in
Ibbenbüren was auch so dass diese
Bandidos ein besonderes Patch dafür
haben wollten expect no mercy dass sie
ganz harte sind und das soll auch eine
Motivation gewesen sein bei diesem
Tötungsdelikt
wenn ihr Lust habt gibt es zu diesem
Thema viel zum Nachhören bei Tatort
Deutschland ich sage euch vielleicht am
besten einmal kurz wie die Episoden
heißen dann könnt ihr die direkt hier im
Channel einmal suchen Folge 1 Mord im
Wettbüro zweite Folge der Arm im Rhein
und die Tricks der Ermittler und der
V-Mann alias Miami Gianni und das war es
mit der Doppelfolge zum Rockerkrieg
Redaktion Stefan Netze Band und Frank
Schneider Postproduktion durch weight
watch Studios München wir hoffen
natürlich ihr seid doch beim nächsten
Mal wieder dabei euer Mirko und eure
Toni